I mean I'll be able to take you from the
Volvo to sink on sink then back to the
volleyball you know you know what and
what I can do is make sure to be a
chicken noodle soup when you're sick
um is there a Medicare because this
gonna need to be checked
I would say my definition of rizz is
every single time I've talked ever
if you're gen Z you know what rizz is
it's just using your personality and
Charisma to and romantically entice a
girls like it's like an all-encompassing
thing right it's the whole package right
right so it could be the looks it could
be your personality it could be the
jokes could be your pickup lines because
you're witty it's also your approach
though too yeah like yeah you can't just
come up to a woman be like oh hey I
think you're gorgeous like you you can't
be awkward you can be cringe that is the
number one risk killer even if you're
not that good looking if you got mad Riz
if you got mistress
that's 100 true so how do we how do we
want to shake this up I would say you
said that you would like sing to women
in public yeah yeah that's first place
because I would not want to do that
that's confidence
it's not confidence and talent that is
confidence and talent what about you
guys I think you're funny
I think you're funny I think you're
really funny what's your go-to move
[Laughter]
all right
I feel like it has to be more in the
moment yeah it's more of a moment thing
because I don't I don't use pickup lines
because anyone could Google a pickup
line that's what I'm saying well that's
the thing it's like pick up lines can be
cheesy but I feel like in the right
context they could also be effective
knowing that it's cheesy I'm so ready
for your pickup life
I didn't say I had any good ones I think
you should probably be number three yeah
I think you should be I think you should
be enough I mean you're you're rizzling
on Dave and it's working that's a crazy
thing nut number one
number one for sure
wait but every time you talk it's rizz
that's true yeah
you're kind of leading the conversation
right now I feel like that's a up the
line sort of thing okay I think I'm a
middle of the paper
oh guys come on here this entire time
I mean I don't mean or anything but yeah
I should definitely be up there
yeah yeah
I think so I think so I'll let you all
stop do it do it
thank you
how do I feel about this I feel good I
feel this I feel this is perfect I was
just happy to be here
Knuckles I'm number one I'm just happy
to be here
[Music]
Riz is cringe am I wrong no right okay
wait what no you're not wrong no you're
correct I mean like I guess a guy can
try to like res you and be cringe but
like if he has good game and he's smooth
with it then like I personally don't
think it can be cringed I'm with her
yeah but like cringe rizz is like the
common pickup line type but like a good
Riz would be charismatic positive
confidence right if they Googled how do
I hit on a female like no it's like I'm
cringing yeah I like confidence just not
cocky so if you like approach me like
you are entitled already and like I
should just automatically go out to you
just because you tried I turned them
away right very easily and it's like you
don't have to be super confident as long
as you put yourself out there and funny
yeah
but if you got like you know Immaculate
risk then you're attacked yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
so I was trying so hard
let's start with you round one
uh let's see we're at a Well Bar you
said uh yeah sure okay bar I see you're
buying a drink
um where's mine
no unfortunately
uh okay the other cheesy pickup line
that I had you're gonna tell me it's
cheesy before you tell me one that I
thought of was uh are you a camera
because every time I see you you make me
want to smile
this is two minutes
right back right back right back okay hi
it's nice to meet you hi it's nice to
meet you
I'm Logan uh what's your name my name is
I think you look really great tonight
thank you I do too well I like that you
have confidence thank you can I get you
a drink no okay okay great let's cut it
there
let me finish you guys just started
laughing I'm not old enough to drink
okay how'd you get in here
I'm trying to catch a case though
it was a pleasure
yeah I was the first person like kind of
the Icebreaker of the entire activity so
I had no plan whatsoever and thought of
a pickup line and then
fouled out
hey how's it going again
I like it I appreciate it all right so
what you got
I don't do pick-up lines so I'm just
gonna try to get to know guys where are
you from New Jersey New Jersey I'm in
Philly oh really East Coast okay
yeah how do you like it over here it's
not my favorite but like I'm more of a
person that's wanting to like travel
everywhere rather than just like one
place and stay in that one place
favorite spot where you want to go
probably Amsterdam Amsterdam really yeah
what I want a backpack in Europe for
like six months a little Euro trip thing
exactly I see you have a lot of tattoos
you got a fair one probably this one
this is why I moved to L.A really I
actually do art too I sell my artwork
let's see I would actually get a artwork
like touching I've done that so many
times
really I was gonna say if you ever need
any artwork I got you sick cool he's
nice
thank you hi nice to meet you nice to
meet you what's your name Emily Emily
yeah we're kind of matching it's kind of
a Vibe doesn't it I kind of like to sing
a lot so if I say serenade me right now
I could serenade you okay would you like
me to serenade you yeah can we talk for
a minute girl I want to know your name
but you said your name was Emily though
yeah what do you do for uh work I'm in
clinical research okay yeah what about
you I am a full-time College athlete
okay uh for what sport uh basketball so
can you dunk me or no
I can do more than that
but I can show you later oh okay
[Music]
hello hello hello
um listen
I may not be able to give you I may not
be the richest one here and I may not be
the most handsome One here
but listen I mean I'll be able to take
you from the wall by the sink on sink
then back to the Volvo if you know you
know what but what I can do
is make sure to be a chicken noodle soup
when you're sick
make sure I just cry right now
I want to be I want to make sure to pick
you up when you fall
and I want to make sure you're the best
version of yourself
um is there a Medicare because the
students
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I have like a in and out gift card if
you want to go yeah I'll buy you ever
yeah I got like multiple meals on there
if you want to go to in and out or like
Shake Shack we could go whatever you
ever asked me one question about myself
all right listen but you've told me to
listen four questions
I'll listen to anything you have to say
what do you uh like to do for fun
not
please help me
help me let's move on
I'm so sorry yeah so I basically kind of
threw in the beginning I got a little
bit nervous when I came in she was so
pretty I just didn't want to get last to
be honest anything but last
okay
hi hi I'm Tiffany Tiffany I'm Dave my
pronouns are he in him but I want to be
yours
I play Valerian so I've heard that right
you put a bell I do will you will you
carry me I need someone to carry me are
you immortal
no I'm sober what rank are you you're
silver
I'm flat God I used to work for a
company called riot games
yeah so why'd you quit uh to start my
own startup oh good job thanks what do
you do oh I um I'm an advisor for a
management agency and I also do content
creating oh that's so cool do you do
valorant content creation
um I think my gym stuff does better than
like like or like any like yeah yeah
so I could get your IG
yeah
you gotta think about it first yeah you
can get it okay thank you that seems
like it went well let's move on I think
it would be nerve-wracking in the bar
regardless but there's no alcohol no
music it's all quiet everyone is
standing there it's like a dance battle
without the dancing hi hi what's your
name my name is
very nice to meet you nice to meet you
too tell me are you in college school or
anything or I am in school cool where
we're at I go to RCC RCC no way you're
from Riverside yes I'm from Riverside
area that's completely coincidental by
the way wow wait oh you're being serious
what are you majoring in I'm an English
major English Okay cool so you can write
like thesis statements and okay cool
nice anyway tell me what's your favorite
band
yeah I don't think I listen to bands
that much
anything do you know do you know
what I'm working I'm working do you know
the killers
you've never heard of The Killers
Coldplay yeah you have to know Coldplay
okay
no way I'm gonna see them in September
artist then his favorite artist that you
currently have on repeat probably Maggie
Lindemann she's married
Maggie Lindemann I haven't heard of her
pop punk like alternative cool yeah was
that good you kind of scared me I'm not
going
but what's that w rizz at least
[Laughter]
um
I Love This Bar how's it going what's up
I'm Kim nice to meet you Cam I'm Jess
you can call me nut though if you want
that wasn't like a weird that's like my
people call me that why it's like my
music name I do music
so did you do you like squirrels
oh they're cool
yeah why'd you ask me that
can I get you a drink because we're at
the bar
um no I'm okay I didn't even want to get
you one
I'm kind of Flushed for cash right now
oh no oh yeah the nut music isn't
working it's not surprisingly not going
that great oh no yeah who would have
thought so like what's up
do you do any impressions
I have one oh can I see it Obama let's
hear it
Michelle
thank you
it's really good does that change thanks
for you
um no but maybe you could start doing
impressions more Impressions yeah you
should practice I only have the one
that's it I have more race
thank you so much
what was the longest relationship you
guys had three years three years yes
I've actually never been in a
relationship okay never had a girlfriend
eight years eight yep that's your wife
go find her I
used to be married I'm a divorced yeah
so thanks for I'll carry you
okay thank you thank you four years
five and a half years
two
two and a half what's your biggest red
flag in women
if your music taste isn't there it's not
gonna work you know hey nothing my red
flag would be like being it unable to
articulate or communicate her feelings
if the girl is not down to have fun like
let's say you're singing in the car and
she's like stop like that's weird like
people are watching that's probably
laziness because I like to be active and
go out and do stuff I mean I get staying
and watching Netflix or whatever but
like I like to go out and do stuff I
think mine would have to be energy
levels in terms of like if they can
match you or not and that's not always
like 24 hours but if they just can't
ever hit that level of just matching
your Vibe then it's not there what's
your number one red flag of yourself
live too much weights
foreign
[Music]
I troll like
insanely like a lot so I don't know
y'all would be able to what do you mean
like just mess with it because I'm
thinking Internet troll and I'm like
like if I find something that you don't
like I will like immediately why it's
just a troll just to make you mad but
playfully not anything well maybe a
little bit just to like push your
buttons but just a little giggle I'm
always late like everywhere
straight up I was told that I care too
much like I care a lot for a person when
I am attracted to them that's a great
point
I dance Too Much I dance everywhere I go
mine I don't know I'm a procrastinator
so like I probably plan something last
minute like a gator I'll be ready last
minute so we're kind of late I think
mine would have to be I'm a little
stubborn I learned from my dad sorry Dad
good answers guys do you ladies feel
like you have enough information to go
off of to make a decision
oh
[Music]
so you guys great
babe I'm sorry like the whole troll
thing like got us a little like
questioning like how much of a troll
you're great Shake It Off All right so
six oh Jaden I mean I just didn't want
to get lost
the chicken noodle song I I dissociated
the whole
thing to me I was so confused I think
you were nervous and you were a lot
sweeter in your answers afterwards but
not the chicken noodle part
okay so next was Logan yes really we
didn't like your first impression we
just thought we thought you were playing
Mr like mean like cool guy and also like
it's too cold it kind of came off like
maybe you aren't used to having to do
the risk you know like maybe you are
used to getting risked so no I I don't
approach people at the bar actually
really easy I sit in the corner it's
okay I do too I could tell if you would
have started with the second half I
would have been like I I liked you
towards the end I did I really did four
it was red shirt
[Music]
if a guy were to come up to me and start
singing probably not they were that's
probably like a second or third date
thing that's like a fourth yeah yeah if
I like you I'm serenading you and that's
okay it just came out you know on the
field but yeah all right third place
Dave we like how like really friendly
and open you were also the fact that
like you tolerated someone for eight
years they tolerated you yeah
for sure for sure I like that you guys
give a lot of feedback too this is a
very very constructive Dynamic yes and
then second place we have nuts
yeah
I have to be honest it was unanimous
except for me she was not for you I
wasn't oh you were the only one who
didn't yeah and you're the one that I
talked to that's hilarious
no but you're like light-hearted you're
like dorky cute yeah
women love
love don't talk at someone like make it
maybe a little more personal what do you
think got you to the top uh training
hard work dedication we did practice Riz
on each other in the back and I I raised
in the bathroom beforehand also and
yes
you just like maintained eye contact and
you actually like cared about the other
person you weren't just like trying to
swoop in and just get to the point
you're like let me learn more about you
and that's the thing I feel like a lot
of men lack it's just like I just want
my one and done I want to feel powerful
for this one second but it seems like
you're a genuine person I appreciate it
I appreciate it thank you nice but you
all did so good
[Applause]
while this was humbling but just
continue to be yourself everyone has
their own opinion I respect that but uh
I don't know I'll work on it Lee said
that he was a troll there are troll
girls out there that he'll find like a
shorty like you know and they'll like
troll together be yourself be genuine
play your strengths just be like Errol
he's the RIS master all Arrow what a
baddie I could not do what they just did
today that is terrifying just being in
front of someone and just giving it your
all like seriously like all of them I
was it was impressive
subscribe to the channel
Michelle
[Applause]